taxes so right now we got you know we
put the number between 80 to 120 whether
it's our national debt or unpaid or on
you know medicare so put them all
together 80 to 120 trillion dollars that
we got a libertarian person you become a
president 2024 you win what happens to
our taxes what do you do well i mean uh
i would work
to repealing every tax that i possibly
could i mean there's nothing the the i
mean if you're talking about the debt
that we have that's one thing and the
only answer to that is to is to um
essentially cut spending and default on
what we're going to default on because
there's no way we could ever tax
ourselves the 100 trillion dollars in
unfunded liabilities that we have coming
up over the next few decades but look my
buddy scott horton who's everyone here
knows a brilliant libertarian he always
puts it this way right but if you're
thinking about like the income tax
imagine we didn't have an income tax we
didn't have an irs and we were just
living in like a free country and uh the
vladimir putin invaded or let's say the
soviet union invaded and conquered
america and they took over you know they
created the uss irs they said now we
have this organization and we have just
dictated in this country that um
producing things is a crime being a
productive member of
society is a crime and the punishment is
a fee and the more productive you are
the higher your fee is going to be and
we are suspending the fifth amendment
you no longer have the right to not
incriminate yourself you are legally
obligated to incriminate yourself every
single year you no longer have the right
to privacy you must give us all of your
information and we will look over we
will ruin your life if we want to we
will destroy families lead to suicides
go back 20 years if we want to and
demand all of your records if that was
created we would all very clearly go we
have been taken over by a totalitarian
regime and this is not the way that free
people live there it is it is despicable
in a professed free society that we have
an irs or an income tax i would abolish
it as soon as i possibly could um and
then abolish all other taxes as well
there's there's no need for any of this
whole system and it doesn't even matter
i mean look at the way we print money
and spend money it's completely
untethered from how much tax revenue we
raise what do you do with the debt you
owe to china and japan well i think that
um there's basically the
whether this happens now or later there
we're going to end up defaulting on this
debt in one of several different ways
now same like we did with the gold
standard basically this is what richard
nixon did when he took us off the gold
standard it was a big giant default we
had made a promise that we would redeem
our dollars in gold france was like we
want the gold and we were like no you
can't have it because we don't have
enough because we printed way more money
than we have gold to back it up now
whether we do this through printing
money and just basically saying we'll
pay back the debt but it'll be you know
with dollars that are worth much less
than they were when you borrowed them
that's a form of default that default
also destroys your own economy in the
process i think it would be much better
off uh if we were to just uh acknowledge
the reality of the situation which is
that this government is bankrupt does
not have this money
never was in a position where it could
pay this money back the result of that
would probably be our national credit
rating uh being tanked and that people
wouldn't lend us money in the future so
we'd have to drastically shrink the size
of government
which all that's kind of what that's
kind of what i'm looking for anyway the
idea that we that we can pay this money
back without you know destroying the the
country the country is insane and to be
honest i don't think the taxpayer owes
it you know like i don't think the
taxpayer didn't like borrow this money
from people governments borrowed this
money on behalf of the taxpayer this
isn't like a true debt like in a private
sense where you borrowed money this is
like if you borrowed a whole bunch of
money for your children
saying they'll pay back the debt and
then you just bought yourself a bunch of
like jets and you know uh you know a
bunch of nice boats and stuff like that
and tanks right and then they go they go
okay well does your kid owe that money
back i'd say no they didn't borrow the
money i don't think you have a right to
say the next generation owes this money
well and this isn't even i mean it's
it's the next generation too but even
the current generation yeah if i walked
in here with a gun and said uh great
news uh you owe all this money that i
just ran up but the good news is i have
a new house new car knew everything
yachts i started a war uh but here are
you also you now owe all this money you
don't actually owe that money i i i
cringe every time i see a politician go
we're america we pay back our debts good
you pay it back
we didn't consent to this we did not
agree to this we did not sign this this
is not an actual debt that is owed now
another question is okay but without
taxes how does government fund itself
and the short answer to that is they're
going to have to fund themselves when
everyone else funds themselves
voluntarily if you aren't a government
or a criminal organization and in fact a
lot of criminal organizations fund
themselves through voluntary commerce
but the ones that don't that are that
are thugs like how government operates
they fund themselves through extortion
and protection rackets and that's what
government does and surprise surprise
that we don't get the best value out of
a protection racket when someone comes
in and says great place you got here be
ashamed if anything was to happen to it
and then they rob you the end of that
story is that they do a great job
protecting you it's just that they don't
break up your store and they keep
charging you more and more and more so
that they don't break up your store we
need to force government to figure out
how to fight get people to want to give
money to it and there are ways to do
that you can have direct fees for
services you can have like a voluntary
transaction fee which would basically be
like a small insurance policy on any
transaction you do if you want to pay it
fine if you don't find if you don't pay
it you're not protected you can't use
the courts to sue if something goes bad
with that transaction or whatever and in
doing it that way government would have
to make whatever that fee is worth it no
one's going to want to pay a 40 or 50
transfer tax but 5 maybe so now that
forces government to actually live
within its means because right now it
actually government does live within its
means it means is whatever amount of
money it tells the federal reserve to
run up and lend to it we needed to live
with them within the means of what we
wanted to do and the only way that's
ever going to happen is taking away its
ability to extort all of us under threat
of harm there's a big problem here
though most americans are happy with
taxes
in fact every time they do polling no
matter what it is every time a year
whoever runs the polls you can check one
now in life if you want to what do
americans think about taxes there's
always a chunk of americans who
literally say we're not taxed enough
so americans overall are okay with taxes
so we have to change the american psyche
on taxes absolutely i think the first
step is believe it or not simplifying
all the tax codes is the number one
thing as president i would push is to
simplify all that i'd have to fight all
the accountants fight all the finance
industry
fight all the tax prep people but
simplify the tax code do you want a flat
tax what would you want flat tax is fine
everyone pays x percent you you as long
as it's zero i'm cool with it well
that's a joe jorgensen no but the first
no that's a ron paul line joe jorgensen
was i'm cool with any new tax plan as
long as the rate is zero percent so what
what but you wanna you wanna make sure
that the people will accept it and
people are gonna be unhappy if everyone
pays the same rate it's just how
americans are so you've gotta somehow
say whatever is the poverty rate say for
the sake of argument eighteen thousand
dollars so any money up taking thousand
dollars is untaxable that makes people
who are worried about taxing the poor
feel safe
after that one dollar to say eighteen
thousand or whatever number i made the
number up but say after that is now
taxed at a flat fee ten percent five
percent i don't care what the percent is
no matter what that's the percent
however you get your money in that's the
percent number one second i don't want
to take money out of out of paychecks i
want people to write a check for their
taxes in april that's how we collect
taxes i want you to write that check to
pay your taxes every year so you're
feeling it i already know i already do
it yes the average person that comes out
of your paycheck that's correct i want
you to go i'm writing a check am i
getting what i want out of this what
1099 and business owners do yes
you know the crazy thing you should do
you know the crazy thing that will
change we can do what they're talking
about do you know who came up with tax
withholding and when he was on his math
that he was the
biggest regret oh man of my life milton
friedman is that right yeah i know that
i know this is the reason for it
and he said it's the biggest mistake i
made fyi
in
1862
lincoln said we need money folks he went
and taxed america wasn't a big number
seven percent i think was tears of three
percent six percent some small number
like that civil war he said once we pay
off the civil war we'll stop taxes do
you think taxes stop
it did nine years later there was no
taxes because we paid it off nice and
then the next time around 1903 all this
other time that's when everything else
showed up so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you